well are conquering the quarantine
series
it's airing all week long here on good
day las vegas in the six o'clock
hour we're looking at different ways to
have
people uh have they're looking at
different ways people rather have
past the time over the past year whether
it's
as we saw yesterday nate making some
spicy mayo or as we're finding out today
it's a little different
that's right and because of the pandemic
you know we've all spent a lot more time
stuck in our homes than ever before alex
yes we have
and many people chose to adopt or foster
a pet during the pandemic
it's great news for animals at local
shelters but it's also helped so many of
us
get through this tough year the walks
wags and smiles we needed them more than
ever this past year
and our pets were there as our homes
transformed into offices and classrooms
we got to spend more time with our fur
babies and as the pandemics continued
more found their forever homes dora
baby girl rachel diehl fostered dora
from the animal foundation
during the holidays we got her because
we were gonna be home alone for the
holidays and
thought it'd be great to give a pup a
place to you know to stay
and don't have to be in the shelter
after just a couple of days
they knew dora would become part of the
family my boyfriend and i we were foster
fails
in 2020 over 8 thousand animals were
adopted from the animal foundation alone
sometimes we get hundreds of phone calls
in the morning to our adoption hotline
as more people foster and adopt the
foundation is also getting fewer animals
into the shelter
a couple years ago you might have heard
stories about a dog that was here for
200 days 300
days we're just not really seeing that
right now which is a good thing i think
the dog who's been here the longest
right now is maybe 12 days
which that's amazing our dogs have
gotten us outside and
forced us to be active you're doing it
for somebody else you're doing it for
you know another being and so it keeps
us kind of active
and happy say hi friends
they've protected the house provided
companionship
and some became more talented than we
ever will be
our pets have given us comfort and joy
in a year we needed it the most
i can't even tell you how much happiness
she brings she is
she's she's a reason to wake up in the
morning and smile
you can't buy more than that oh those
dogs are so cute
yeah so you still do need to make an
appointment to see an animal at the
animal foundation
and we've got that all on our website
for you but yes we owe it to our pets i
think for
entertaining us giving us a bit of humor
in this year absolutely
should we give a quick little pet shout
out ourselves this morning a little bit
where's oh oh there he is here's my bobo
there's beauty yes i am a bodhi's mom to
us to some uh
oh my gosh his trainer threw him a
birthday party
for his first birthday with other dogs
that made him food and everything so yes
he's had a nice life oh there's our
christmas card where our cat mink was
saying i really don't want to be part of
this and here she is receiving
new instructions from her home planet
oh she's such a beauty mate thank you
she adopted us
yeah he's uh he was laying on my lap
petey became pretty popular while
we were all working at home and nala
loves her daily dose of sunshine sitting
out on the patio
she just likes to sit out there and soak
up some vitamin d
and there she is at christmas oh they're
so cute
all adopted from different uh shelters
and organizations and john
and of course as we've talked about
before here's my tyrannosaurus rex
mark just a real source of
comfort during this pandemic has helped
make sure that there's no bugs around
the house
and also helps just to quickly toast my
bread
for the bread he can't hold up like this
and it takes care of it this much
this much